hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series of
the hazel engine series as I guess I can
call it now last time we talked about
setting up a basic visual studio project
and solution all that and actually
having kind of a hazel library link
against the sandbox application if you
guys haven't seen that episode make sure
you check it out because that was the
first episode in which we wrote any code
in this episode we're going to continue
on with writing code we kind of just
wrote more of a test last time that
really just showed kind of how we could
interact I guess between that static
library or the dynamic library that we
built which was our hazel engine and
then also the actual sandbox application
that we have but it was really rough and
today we're gonna set it up a little bit
more properly and specifically we're
gonna actually start by creating an
entry point so let's talk a little bit
about what that actually means so when
we talk about kind of writing
applications I guess there's always an
entry point to that application unless
it's like some kind of static library
like even dynamic libraries have entry
points and we can kind of talk about
that I think a little bit later in this
series as well but essentially our
application needs to start somewhere
right
what is what happens when we launch our
application well we know certain code
will essentially run and then from there
we probably want to somewhat take
control and say well okay all of this
kind of engine startup code needs to
actually happen now there's many
different ways that we could do it for
example because our and our engine is a
dll file DLL files also have kind of a
main function
so basically we're allowed to call
certain code when either we attach that
dll process or when we detach it so in
other words if for the if our
application loads the DLL or unloads the
DLL we can kind of hook into those
events and just say I want to run this
code and that's fine but because we are
building kind of an engine that is
essentially an application engine as
climene sure it's a game engine but what
is a game engine right a game engine is
a real-time kind of application engine
it doesn't just have to apply to games
and certainly hazel is not necessarily I
probably might not even brand it
necessarily as a game engine because
it's capable of so much more than that
and it will be capable of so much more
than that
so because we kind of it's an engine on
which we can build applications it's
kind of important for us essentially to
just be able to say okay well I'm going
to provide a way for hazel applications
to actually create their entry point we
could just write a main function in our
application in fact if we look over at
the code that we currently have we have
this application or CBP file which is
inside sandbox and that just has many
I'll just make this a bit bigger we just
have that main function void main and
that calls hazel print and all that
stuff's fine basically what I'm saying
is I don't want this to be here because
this means that this kind of how the
main function is defined is up to the
application whereas this is something
that I would like to take control of
from the engine side so that's what
we're gonna talk about today it's gonna
be kind of a simple set up I don't think
it will take too long and just as a
short kind of disclaimer with everything
in the series this series obviously I'm
writing as I go and as far as any kind
of software engineering project is done
this is subject to change in the future
so if I decide that actually like let's
do it a bit differently like this is not
final code in any sense
we're running a game engine together I
haven't got a game engine written and
then I'm just showing you step-by-step
how I bought that end product
no we're writing an engine together here
so obviously things may change over time
anyway without further ado let's just
jump in and start programming and I'm
just gonna show you guys how to make an
entry point we're also gonna make an
application class that will essentially
be a way for us to actually like launch
our obligation and define an application
inside our sandbox project and we're
also probably going to need to get that
decals decals spec DLL import and export
functions into a macro so that we can
actually you know reuse header files and
not do what we've done here which is
essentially having to manually kind of
import this void print thing manually
have this function declaration here with
the DLL M import and then over here
as you can see we had that export so
anyway the first thing that I want to do
is inside sauce I'm going to add a new
folder called hazel and everything's
kind of going to go into here so this is
going to be kind of the hazel core
library this test stuff I'm just gonna
flat out delete because I don't care
about any of that and then inside hazel
I'm going to make a few new items I
really want to make something called
well I'm gonna make something called
core build age which for now I'm calling
a quarter age this will have some basic
mappers to begin with and I also want to
make my kind of application I can
probably make a simple plus class called
application and then hopefully it will
create a header file for me and a CPP
file let's just hit OK that's pretty
basic
it saves a bit of typing if I offer over
here you can see we've got some
definitions as well so I'll start by
taking this application class and
putting it into the hazel namespace the
hazel namespace is we didn't talk too
much about naming or anything like that
but essentially everything is going to
be in the hazel namespace and for macros
they will most likely be shortened to Hz
like that instead of kind of making an
HSN namespace like this which you could
do that's quite a popular approach so
now at least
well whatever for this hazel engine I
decided to kind of go with the actual
full word like that and if we switch
over to the CPP file I'm going to do the
exact same thing name space hazel and
we're going to wrap it like that I'm
going to write a void run here which is
basically just going to run our
application and for now this is going to
be incredibly simple I'm literally just
gonna stick a while true loop in here
like that
just so that we can kind of just have an
infinitely running application that
won't close for now the other thing
that's really important to do is make
this destructor virtual because this
class will actually be inherited
worldsuck last by our actual sandbox
application because the way that we're
going to write this as you see in a
minute is essentially we're going to
make our
application which inherits from hazel
application okay cool that's looking
pretty good to me
we have the big problem here of having
to actually decals spec DLL export and
import depending on where it's kind of
written this actual application like
this okay so in order to actually use
this class inside sandbox because this
is a DLL we need to export it from that
hazel DLL so when we build this has
hazel DLL this needs to be DLL export
and then when we include application of
age inside application or CPP in our
sandbox project this actually needs to
be DLL import the same way that we had
with our print function except here is
with the entire class so to do this and
to make it a lot easier for ourselves
we're actually going to go to that core
header file that we made by the way
application should be inside that hazel
um thinks I'm just gonna move it into
there inside core I'm just going to find
a macro that is either either DLL import
or export depending on whether or not
we're building this DLL file so the way
we're going to do that is very simple
first of all do explore deco spec do
export and import is a Windows only
thing I want to say if def H said
platform Windows okay so this only
applies to Windows one one more level
deep I'll say if def H said build DLL
which means we're trying to build this
DLL min which will this macro will be
defined for this actual hazel project
but not for sandbox we're gonna say
define hazel API as in deco spec
DLL export end it or other else we're
going to define it as input okay
and I mean we could just put like a
simple kind of else you know error
there's or only supports windows because
that's all we support for now okay just
so that this basically will trigger an
error and one build if if no platforms
are defined which for now I guess is
just this so we're going to grab this
we're going to right-click on hazel go
to properties inside hazel property
pages for all configurations and for our
x64 platform under C C++ preprocessor
we're going to define a couple of macros
so first of all we'll put a couple of
definitions in a step platform windows
will be something that I'll put in here
of course and this actually also needs
to go into sandbox so I look on sandbox
and put a shared platform windows ok
making sure that we have a semicolon and
then additionally in hazel I'm going to
put a macro called hazel build vol I
call the macros their religious
definitions or defines but there we go
so hazel build DLL okay so that's what
we've got in here which means that that
this kind of export should be active
when we build the hazel library but for
sandbox this import should be active so
if we go to application or H I'll
include portal H and then we'll just say
class hazel API application just like
that ok so now that we've done that what
essentially that means is that if we go
into our application or safety which is
in sandbox this is becoming a little bit
confusing because both of these files
are called application bill CBP so I'm
actually going to rename this file to
sandbox does TVP or maybe sandbox app
del CBP just so that we kind of get rid
of that confusion now what I want to do
is I don't really want to in my son
box application have to do stuff like
include you know hazel slash application
but sippy that's kind of hard to use
right what I actually want to be able to
do essentially is just say I want to
include hazel dot H like that okay and
that should sort out everything for me
so what I'm going to do is first of all
inside source over here I'm going to add
a new item called hazel - and this will
kind of be like a header file that is
only intended intended to be included by
client applications so hazel will never
include this you can see it's actually
outside of hazel this is just kind of
for used by applications so this is for
use by hazel vocations okay and inside
here we're going to include hazel stuff
so include hazel application maybe hazel
core whatever we don't really need to
include for but you kind of get the
point we're just going to put everything
that we need kind of into here and then
this will be included here so to make
this kind of work we're going to right
click on sandbox hit properties
we're gonna go to C C++ general and as
an additional include directory I'm
going to say solution directory and then
hazel and then backslash source like
that so we're adding this source folder
as an include directory in sandbox so
that we can actually either you know do
that or doesn't really matter if we use
angular brackets or not but the point is
we can kind of use a compiler include
path even like this or like this to
actually include hazel and we don't have
to use relative plots okay cool
so that's it that's done let's think
about writing actual application now so
we can say class sandbox is public hazel
application okay we can do a number of
things here let's maybe just have a
basic constructor and destructor which
for now we'll do the nothing and then I
mean we only need to do much here but
basically the idea is we kind of have a
skeleton class which is a hazel
location and the idea now is that we
kind of want to run it maybe by doing
something like sandbox sandbox equals
new sandbox we're gonna allocate it on
the heap like this for now making sure
to delete it later and then we'll do
something like sandbox run that's what
we basically want to do okay I don't
want to do this inside sandbox app dot
cpp because this should be somewhat
handled this would this should basically
be handled by the engine and not by the
application where heap allocated it
because sandbox can tend to be very
large and we do want to control the
lifetime of this explicitly because it
is our literally our entire like
application so this does like I
definitely want to be explicit with
memory when it comes to this but if we
run this it should actually work and
hopefully just bring up okay well in
this case actually get a an arrow which
is fantastic so what does it say here
okay inconsistent DLL linkage okay so
it's not happy with our DLL linkage and
in fact yeah so there's something wrong
with the hazel API macro probably I
should say what we actually defined that
as because it should be hazel Bill Doyle
okay I see so we used Hz build DLL here
and hazel build DLL here so let's just
get rid of hazel will just say a chesed
build dll like that and here okay so now
it should actually export that properly
let's build this hazel project and then
we'll build at the sandbox okay and I
don't know why this is void it clearly
should be int I'm not sure what I wrote
last time but let's run this code and
see what happens now if we run this
we're going to get an entry point out
found error the basic reason for this is
because of course we we're not updating
our DLL which now has other stuff in it
so we need to copy that hazel dll to our
sound box and replace the old one
because we've built it now this really
should be a post build step from hazel
or like a virtual staff from sandbox
really that does this for us but you can
see that now we get an application that
runs kind of infinitely right it's not
going to do anything because we've just
got a while true loop there
it is kind of loading in the hazel
application okay so now that we've done
that we've actually kind of done the
majority of the work here we've created
all these macros that actually either
export or import our symbols and we've
written a basic entry point now what I
want to do is actually inside hazel make
a header file called entry point which
will basically define that main function
for us so entry point don't H and then
this is just going to be a header file
which will probably just say if def I
imagined this entry fun will change
based on platform so we'll say if def
page said platform windows and we might
just stick our our arrow up not really
required we could stick this in here
just like that every time that we do
that but of course if we have it at
least once especially in a file like
court or age it should just not build if
if hazel only supports windows Kay make
sure there's no typos all right so
basically what this will do is fairly
simple it's just going to be this int
main function like that that's going to
create our hazel application for us now
this I will fill out with oxy and RV we
most likely want this to be win main on
windows because we might want to retain
certain information about how the
program was run just for kind of Windows
like when 32 API purposes but we won't
worry about that for now now what we
actually need though is some way to
create an application now sandbox we
don't know it's gonna be sandbox and I
don't want to set up some weird like
macros or anything like that so all I'm
going to do is say that somewhere we're
going to have a something that returns
the hazel application pointer so extern
hazel application like that and we'll
say something like hazel create
application I think that that would be
okay so basically what this is is a
function that we will define somewhere
else which will actually return that
application for us so create application
is something that we will implement in
the client so this is all going to make
sense
Minnis we're actually gonna end up
defining this well declaring this
function inside application or H so over
here I'm just going to write a function
which is essentially application create
application that's what we call for now
and this is something that is should be
defined in client okay which means that
inside our sandbox app which I'll just
pin over here we need to actually say
basically instead of this main entry
point we need to basically say that
hazal application create application is
going to return in our case a new
sandbox class instance right which is
our actual application that we've built
okay and that's it
so if we go back to entry point just to
see kind of how this will look like
don't worry about any of the arrows at
all but this is basically what we end up
with this is an extern that will be
found somewhere else in in our case
inside sandbox app and all that this is
going to do is upon main you know will
actually didn't type any code that's
great but basically up on main and we
can just order this order app equals
hazel create application just like that
and then we're gonna do a run and then
I'm going to delete app ok so this will
basically just create our application
for us by calling this function and then
it will call the run function on side
application which will do our while true
loop and then at the end it will kind of
delete it okay so that is how that works
now we need to include this entry point
inside hazel and just to make it kind of
really obvious I might say something
like entry point just to kind of make it
I guess obvious that this is where it is
and I'm just going to
include hazel slash entry point okay and
then hopefully we will be able to not
have not have to have a main function in
the at all if I right click and hit
build we get a linking error the
carbocation is an unresolved external
and the reason that has happened here is
because of course this needs to be a
hazel trait application so we will right
click and build that and then you can
see we get no errors at all and if I run
this code we kind of get the same result
okay so the difference I guess is that
we've actually moved this entry point
into being inside the hazel engine right
and I could even say something like
printf you know hazel engine or
something I don't know just for the
meantime and if I run that I might need
to actually include something so let's
just include stdio.h far on this you can
see that we get hazel engine printing so
essentially everything is kind of fine
I'll get rid of about these two things
for now because that was the test and
we've essentially kind of moved the pain
of creating this kind of main function
and doing everything properly to the
actual engine side so if we look at our
client side all we need to do is include
hazel create our kind of sandbox class
and just write a function which
essentially returns this you could
automate this even further if you wanted
to but I quite like this base it's very
simple we can do extra code here if we
really need to upon kind of creating our
application but it's just really really
simple really clean and you can see that
we've basically set up and and
effectively like an antenna entry point
for our entire engine and game so that's
pretty cool okay so that's our entry
point done we now have a basic entry
point into our our actual application
and our engine which is very important
because that's where everything kind of
goes from that entry point it's not
defined that it's but it's very simple
for us to actually start kind of
building applications or at least having
an entry point into the applications
that we build using the hazel engine now
you just saw me try and print have
something and I like I mean I couldn't
really and this kind of brings me
- what's gonna happen in the next
episode and our next kind of big task
which is going to be to actually add a
logging support to the engine because
logging is one of the most important
things that we can do like at all we
need some kind of feedback on what's
actually going on and just you know all
the startup information just everything
really so next episode we're actually
going to use a logging library to start
being able to log events or log any kind
of information that we need into the
console and possibly into files as well
so that's what we're going to move onto
next time I just wanted to kind of
define a basic entry point because I
think that this in general is something
that people just forget all the time
just being able to actually say I'm
writing an application that uses the
hazel engine how on earth does that
application start what am I meant to do
and we've kind of defined that right now
which is pretty exciting now before we
leave it at this today I do want
actually push this code to github and
I'll kind of show you guys how I do that
just for fun so I showed the creation of
this Haslett repository last time in
fact it's already got 108 stars on
github which is quite interesting
because I haven't actually even released
that video yet but here we have our
Haslett repository let's actually push
all the code that we've done today it's
that repository so I'm going to go to
this dev hazal directory which is the
directory of this solution I'm going to
open a command prompt window over here
and I'm going to type in a get status
just to make sure that were that
everything is kind of fine now the
biggest thing that I don't want is
obviously this dot vs directory I do not
want that to be kind of included at all
so what I'm going to do is actually set
up a gear ignore so I'm going to just
open vs code here and I'll make a new
file called git ignore inside this hazal
directory you can see here it is and all
I'm going to do is I just had a nice
comment it just says kind of directories
and I'm going to include I want to
ignore a couple directories here so the
first thing is going to be dot vs and
then with bin and bin ends I'm going to
ignore them for now we will probably
commit binaries in some form in the
future so this is somewhat temporary but
now if I run that same get status you
should see that we don't actually have
vs or be an indoor bin in here which
means I can just simply
and get an asterisk and we don't on to
get status you can see we have basically
everything we want dot user is also
something I do not want to commit so
files and we'll say dot B user and if we
go back here just to get rid of all of
these files that we've just added to get
we'll just do get ring set and just dot
and if you're on a status again you'll
see that we don't have anything so if we
do a git add asterisk again and do a
status you should see that we actually
still have user because I need to add an
asterisk at the front there so let's do
that whole process again get reset get
add get status you can see we no longer
have those files here at all and that
looks really good for everything that I
actually want to commit I'm gonna say
git commit and I'll just basically say
set up set up basic application and
entry points and then I'm just going to
do a git push origin master and then it
would actually push it but I'm not
actually going to do this until the
episode goes live for everyone because I
kind of like to keep the repository
actually synchronized with the video
release days ok so there we go
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did you can hit that like button you
can also help support this series by
going over to patreon icon for slash the
Cherno huge thank you as always to all
the patrons that make this series
possible the next episode of this game
engine series is actually already up for
patrons if you're watching this live on
youtube you can watch the next episode
right now if you just go over to patron
icon flash the Turner and help support
this series also all of this code that
I've written I've actually already
written it it's in a private kind of
development branch that patrons have
access to so if you would like access to
basically the future of this series and
like met probably 10 to 20 episodes
ahead like where I've already got the
logging library implemented and all of
that kind of stuff and you potentially
want to help contribute to that kind of
series development branch then you can
also help slow the series and as a
reward you'll have access to all of that
because into this video as always I'll
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]